One of my chords on the rife had a short, so I had not been able to run the
deviant support last week should be getting the ball back tomorrow. So notice
I'm here. Problem with the rife, but she do not try to fix it yourself. You
have a problem with the chord, get it to true rife and get it fixed like this
person did. You know, you might be out of it for a few days, but you it's
worth it getting corrected the right way. Anything else to break up my white blood
cell cone, just your immune support. You just need as much as your, you know,
your aloevia immune product. That's a polysaccharide with a specific chain
polysaccharide that is one of the best things to build up your immune system
medicinal mushrooms, which we have multiple different medicinal mushrooms
techniques on our store, turkey tail mushroom. The my community mushroom
from host offenses, a good one, our medicinal mushroom blend powder is a good one
if you're using the smoothie control in that. I think most of the rife
programs finished completely. Okay, this is a question that somebody emailed in.
So remember, please, please, please, always send your questions in
the member site, not email site. We can't take email questions anymore.
So, but the notice that their rife isn't completely finishing, the
programs aren't completely finishing. So please look at the rife resources
page on your member site. We've addressed this and this is definitely one of
the frequently asked questions. You shouldn't be looking at the numbers on your
rife when you're running your rife, the frequencies that are coming out of the
bulb are also hitting the computer. And they are messing up the, you know,
the computer's ability to really understand what's going on.
So sometimes it deal people will get upset, hey, the count count is not right.
I mean, I still have seven hours to go and I've been running this eight hour
program for six hours already. This is not right. It's because the frequencies are
affecting the computer. Understand, when you hit run on your computer on your
program, it sends the entire program to the box to the little rife machine.
You could unplug the computer. You could take the computer and turn it off.
You could bring the computer in the other room. You could go run over the computer
with your car. The program is still going to run. So it'll run to the,
the whole program will run. So don't worry about that. Don't worry about what
your rife program says afterwards. It's going to get feedback from the frequencies
and mess that up quite often. So don't worry about that.